big news people wondering about the fate
of Sean Spicer people don't know if he's
gonna stick around or not this is the
latest this kind of crazy Trump advisor
Steve Bannon told reporters yesterday
that the White House has been doing
fewer press briefings because Sean
Spicer got fatter
that's what Bannon said Bannon said Sean
Spicer got fatter Ben and then went home
to his mirrorless house I forgot before
I called someone found I would really
check into how I'm looking you know
that's unbelievable there's a there is a
rumor that the White House is gonna find
a new place for press secretary Sean
Spicer a new place yeah well they told
Spicer was it's on a big farm upstate
where you can run and play with all the
other press secretary
and swallow all the gum you wanna
exactly a new study just came out and it
found that after a few months of Donald
Trump most Americans now have a
favorable view of president george w
bush yeah yeah when reached for comment
the ghost of Richard Nixon said here I
come baby that's what you just saw a
Nixon impression in 2017 yeah I know
what the Millennials like hey kid what's
a Nixon yeah you know what I'm talking
about yesterday the u.s. experienced a
series of internet outages all across
the u.s. yeah things got so bad we
momentarily surpassed China in
productivity we actually got something
done
[Applause]
that's my sawing sound in Argentina an
entire trove of Nazi artifacts has been
found hidden in a house yeah you can see
the whole thing on the new reality show
Nazi hoarders you should check that out
that's a good show just whether you like
that and then rapidly you did they
laughter like Oh Nazis a Pennsylvania
man is being awarded eight hundred and
seventy thousand dollars after doctors
removed the wrong testicle yeah yeah or
as he's calling it the ultimate
Powerball win
what kind of move was that I just don't
like that it was after a removed
testicle joke
your reward sorry that I did like that
was intentional I just found the move to
be a look the whole things this is uh
narrable
you